how dark did it get it got pretty dark
for sure um
you know i'm pretty i feel like i'm a
pretty resilient person and i'm a pretty
happy person
in general but
um that was that was definitely a
really difficult time you know i feel
like if we did the just you know just
stay true to who i knew i really was
that it would come out all right and and
learned some lessons along the way no
doubt yeah i mean there was definitely a
few of them that that's been learned and
uh hell man i'm still trying to learn
everything i can
a lot of people around me are like man
you know you're a lot different than you
were even a year ago or whatever you
know and it's just i'm glad to hear that
because that's something that i was it's
not an accident you know i've worked on
it i've tried and i'm glad to see some
of the fruits of my labor come to come
to pass i think i'm happy as i've ever
been i can honestly say that i'm just in
a really good place mentally i got my
little boy i got my family i don't know
man everything is really good for me
right now so our gratitude is at the top
of my vocabulary